[Music]  Gavin Rossdale is moving on from ex-wife  Gwen Stefani here he is kissing 27 year  old German model Sophia Tamala while  taking a stroll out in London keep in  mind this is the first time we've  publicly seen Gavin affectionate with  another woman since his divorce but  maybe everything is not what it seems  Gavin's rep tells ET the two were  friends although Gwen and Gavin have  moved on from each other they do  co-parent their three sons together as  long as your kids are good you're good  yeah I mean for sure that's that's all I  care about  Gavin recently told ety he would never  badmouth his ex right why would I yeah  wouldn't would never do that  it comes real natural to me you not I  mean I mean she's amazing so why would I  think anything less mm-hmm what's the  best thing about her as a mom oh just  how much she loves them  [Music]  you